welcome back the media giving a big
thumbs up to president biden's speech
after four years of a monotone shout
it was bracing to hear a speech
delivered
at times by a whisper i thought it was a
a remarkable speech it's really trying
to bring the country together it was
a make america feel good night make
america feel
pride night i thought the speech was
very carefully and very smartly
crafted in a political way
but the media had a much harsher take on
senator tim scott's gop
rebuttal this is a speech delivered from
a planet where facts don't matter which
is where the current republican party
resides i'm not sure what the purpose of
this was
i am shocked and a bit embarrassed for
him this was a lost opportunity he does
not seem to understand
and a lot of them don't seem to
understand the difference between
um a racist country and
a systemic ra and systemic racism they
don't seem to get the difference
oh my god so dana let's let let's go
back to
tim scott's speech and i want to ask you
if you think it's going to elevate him i
remember with fred thompson a way back
it really put fred thompson on the map
as a presidential candidate
it did not do that for marco rubio or
bobby jindal
what do you think it does for tim scott
again i really think that
you know doing the rebuttal is very very
hard and i think only somebody with um
or oratory or rhetorical or
oratory skills help me greg i think i
can't remember he has good you don't
want help
he speaks real well that's what i want
to say um and
yes there's just no doubt like he is now
elevated that everybody's talking about
him
you know um sometimes unfortunately
trending negatively on twitter with a
racial slur will elevate you to our
people
uh like for example kamala harris was
asked about his very comments last night
by robin roberts this morning on good
morning america tim scott said it's not
a racist country what do you think
she said i agree it is not a racist
country but we have issues we have to
deal with
and then as you pointed out juan what is
tim scott doing he's not just out giving
speeches and raising money
he actually is rolling up his sleeves
and working on the legislation so
i think that yes it definitely elevates
him
it's interesting that the media uh
somebody in the media had that reaction
if they had been with me last night
first of all
peter was really annoying me because we
could uh like beforehand he was flipping
through the channels
we'll talk about the netflix surfing a
little bit we're dealing with that
then i'm like i gotta watch the speech
he sat there and read a book but then
was like from the peanut gallery let's
just say
there were some people who did not like
the speech
well greg i think you didn't like the
speech from what i heard earlier
but i i wanted to ask you if you could
agree that the president did seem to be
in command alert uh not some daughtering
old guy
uh you know which is a lot of the
conservative complaint
it looked like that got blown away last
year the president was alert
problem solved he wasn't he was
conscious no i think the real news here
is that joy reid can be embarrassed i
mean who knew
um yeah by the way the two we had two
joys in that montage and either
they were both joyless look here's the
deal the media is in charge of the
nation's narrative so generally when
they are reviewing something
they're reviewing how well their
narrative is effectively spread
so i used to think that the media was
the bullhorn for the democrats
it's actually the opposite the democrat
party
is the foot soldier for the powerful
people in media they are given the
talking points
and and they're interchangeable with
what you would see on cnn
is exactly what you'd see coming from
the democrats but the difference is
it's coming from the media now it's not
coming from the politicians
so jesse uh i was struck but biden made
a point of saying that you have
mostly good police in this country uh
and then i saw maxine waters applauding
so
to me that looked like a unifying
gesture how'd it look to you
i was happy everybody clapped but i
think greg just made a good point and
when
greg actually makes a good point i think
we should recognize that so that was
really
astute um but juan just to what we were
saying in the a block
biden laid such an egg that might have
been the lowest rated state of the union
ever
by about 20 million and i i think i it's
you should know that people have been
able to stream things for about a decade
so i don't think streaming just started
this year um
i'm disappointed in andrea mitchell and
martha raddatz and brian williams i'm
disappointed and here's why juan
these legends have covered or observed
i don't know the masterful delivery of
ronald reagan
bill clinton's charismatic stemwinders
george w bush's defining
language after 9 11 barack obama's
soaring oratory donald trump's
showmanship and intense patriotic
language and they're going to look at
joe biden's speech and say that was
remarkable
one that's like watching a football game
with all puns and penalties and jim
nance says
that was the greatest game i've ever
seen you'd think jin nance is a [ __ ]
if he told you that you're saying it was
good because he promised to spend more
money than anybody ever
is that is that the barometer right now
someone can tax and spend
really well that's easy there's no
creativity there's no innovation there
he's just buying votes and
redistributing the wealth
anybody can do that we're supposed to
give this guy a big round of applause
because he takes our money and gives it
away and makes more people dependent
come on juan
this wasn't a great speech this was bad
i don't agree but i'm going to take your
point and go to katie katie
let's just forget the pundits then but
the american people in the poll
said they liked the speech
well let me see if i can do this
correctly uh
it was the most unifying speech since
the civil war
and everybody who criticized tim scott
is a raging racist and they should be
cancelled
left's rules not mine there you go
all right